hope you can see this is Tian Jian she's
the female she's the smaller of the two
we've been here since about half-past
8:00 this morning and she's obviously
very very relaxed with all this media
attention today because this is the
first day that the general public are
actually getting to see them it has been
a bit crazy but I think everyone has
been well behaved as well as the pandas
and two lucky people who've been first
in the queue to see the pandas today is
Louise and her daughter Eve first of all
what was it like when you first saw them
it was absolutely fantastic it was very
excited to to meet the meal first of all
in in it is inside enclosure it's lovely
very exciting and Eve what was your
first feeling when you saw them because
you've actually done quite a bit of
research about pandas at school yeah
there are a lot smaller smaller than I
thought and the femur seems to be moving
a bit more as well I heard she was quite
lazy yeah and I noticed you've got the
bobble hat which I have to say is it is
a panda hat yeah there is a use of the
two black eyes what what do you think is
the real attraction why do pandas really
stir this emotion in people I think it's
because they're endangered and people
I'd like to keep fortunately they're in
decreasing so I just wanted to keep them
here yeah and what about the fact that
these are the first pandas in what 17
years in the United Kingdom I think it's
very exciting as Ned but and it's new to
us and we can access them it's nice
tough something for us and Scotland so
that makes it nice so this is going to
be a first and many visits to yes
absolutely use only one of them before
children will all be here if we go
across here hopefully we can just have a
chat with the chief executive of
Edinburgh Zoo how's it gone this morning
this is the first time the public who
have seen the pandas this is the first
public opening for thunder's yeah I
think it's gone pretty well actually
it's just fantastic seeing everyone
enthusiastic it's a pretty chilly
morning which is great for the pandas
because they love it like this and he's
been asleep inside why not seize his
privilege I think then she's chosen to
come out and she's been performing
beautifully I mean she just is so at
home
she's enjoying yourself she seems to
react well to the visitors well she just
seems to get on with her life so it's
just a dream absolutely great thanks
very much for listening we we can't sign
off without having a final look at see
auntie Anne you can see she looks very
relaxed and she is exploring her
enclosure here and she seems very happy
and she's not fazed by all this
publicity